when Stargate returned will we get a
conclusion to the SGU well I think we
will but it might not be the way we
hoped
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
When Brad Wright first started talking
about bringing Stargate back and his
deal with MGM to write a pilot script he
on more than one occasion mentioned that
he'd really like to see a conclusion to
the Stargate Universe story he wanted to
save Eli and Russian young and bring the
entire crew home but time has moved on
the story has moved on we still don't
have any official word on what Amazon
planned to do with Stargate but if you
are a regular side tracker you'll know
that the rumor mill has continued and
that I've been talking to lots of people
at working around Amazon and MGM and
they've been telling me about a lot of
the ideas that are being pushed forward
at the very least
the kind of structure that Amazon see
for a Stargate future now that structure
or that plan is kind of based roughly
around what they see and Paramount doing
with Star Trek and Disney doing with the
Star Wars TV series
so what we're going to see when Stargate
does return it's almost certainly going
to be 10 episodes two or three series a
year and those series will affect each
other be intertwined with each other as
time goes by it looks less and less
likely that Brad Wright will be at the
helm so what about his promises that
we're going to see a conclusion to the
SGU well if Amazon are really looking at
Star Trek as a model for how to bring
Stargate back and that they're going to
find their own Alex kurdsman to run it
I see it not being a soft or a hard
reboot but something in between it's
going to be basically the gloop reboot
you've seen that stuff you make for kids
if you hit it it's hard but if you touch
it slowly it's soft
it's corn flour and water it's the glue
reboot
and buy a gloop reboot I basically mean
it's not a hard reboot which is a
complete you forget everything happened
before you just completely start again
but it's not soft reboot is where you
have new characters a new story but
everything that happened previously
still happened Star Trek the Next
Generation for example is a soft reboot
Battle Star Galactica the new series was
a hard reboot Star Trek though new Trek
is kind of in between it's not really a
continuation of the story because
wow they seem to forget Canon whenever
they like and they seem to just change
history and change facts we're seeing
that with strange new worlds we
definitely sort of Discovery
um
but at the same time it's not a hard
reboot because they still go back to
things that did happen in the previous
series
I think they'll do exactly the same with
Stargate they all do a hybridization or
a gloop reboot by the way if you do like
the content please consider hitting the
join button and becoming a fully fledged
side tracker you can also go to
sidestrek.com and pick marvelous
merchandise all of these little things
really help the channel also if you're
new to the channel like subscribe hit
that Bell notification and share the
video wherever the hell you want but why
would Amazon do it that way well it's
kind of like the problem they've got
with the Lord of the Rings and the rings
of power they are trying to appease the
hardcore fans the people that have not
just read the books once or read the
books multiple times
as well as the Casual viewers but the
Casual viewers outnumber the hardcore
fans significantly the bulk of the
viewing figures come from people that
like the show maybe even love the show
but are not really hardcore fans
now they're going to have a similar
issue with Stargate there are a number
of really hardcore gauges out there that
are desperate for the show to return we
are the ones that watch this show over
and over and over again
but Amazon wants to attract a whole new
host of casual viewers viewers that
might fall in love with the show
eventually but never really watched sg1
before
so how do you do that
you've got to do that by creating
something a bit new so yes new
characters but also something that is
more modern more in line with the sort
of TV shows that are being made today
something that audiences today of 18 19
20 years old would recognize
you can't really do that by just
repeating what they did before and also
though any new TV show you can't just
repeat what you did before anyway
because even the hardcore fans would
moan about that it would just be
repetition and who needs that
so they've got to walk a very thin line
now one way of doing this is to do what
Star Trek did
get a new showrunner get new blood new
writers new producers take the show in a
different direction but
have little Easter eggs for the hardcore
fans do things for the hardcore fans
regularly that they'll go oh I remember
that
now Star Trek does this all the time
they did it in strange new worlds they
did it with Discovery that's the whole
reason why we got the Enterprise in
Discovery
um they do it with certain episodes
where they flash back to certain things
that happened in the original series or
the Next Generation they bring back old
characters occasionally
I could see Stargate doing exactly the
same and one easy way to do that and one
really easy way to appease a lot of
Hardcore fans
is to answer the SGU question
so how would I do it if I was going to
do it well if you are a regular side
tracker again you'll know that I talked
about an idea to set up the series
called the SGC Stargate command I would
do that as a hub that you would then
hook lots of other TV series off so you
could have two three maybe even four
seasons of 10 episodes of different
shows each year but that they all hover
in and around the SGC so you can have a
core set of characters there for me I
would have something like Daniel Jackson
as um the civilian leader of that you
know nice way of bringing back a
character we all love again another hook
for the hardcore fans to get them on
board
um but then you can actually do
different stories each season so you can
have a season aboard a new BC 305 you
could have a Jaffa series you could have
even flashback prequel series like the
Ancients but actually still hook it and
Center it around the SGC the series
starts something in the SGC happens and
then you flash back and explain what
happened with the prequel series an
obvious thing now to do though is if
you're doing that
is to have an SGU Series so it would be
10 episodes how would I do it I would
start it based around the SGC they got a
new power source something that will
allow them to create a wormhole and
connect to the Destiny without
destroying an entire planet
they do that and they find Eli now for
me I would make this pretty dark and
pretty green I would say that at the end
of the SGU obviously
um everybody was put into stasis and
they had enough power then to get them
to the next galaxy they were going to be
traversing the space in between and it
was going to take at least three years
they only had supplies for a month the
Destiny was very heavily damaged after
its fight with the drones and the base
ship
so for my story I would say that the SGU
doesn't make it that when the Wormhole
connects and a team goes through to the
destiny with this new power source that
will allow them to get hung they find
just Eli
he has just about survived we could see
flashbacks through the couple of
episodes of how he survived how he got
food how he got everything else and then
how he very slowly lost the crew I would
say that the destiny obviously failed it
was very heavily damaged the FDL Drive
damaged and it was just floating dead in
Black space between the two galaxies and
that the power slowly died and the pods
slowly failed
we can see eating like desperately
trying to save the crew but losing them
one by one
we would then obviously I believe see
Eli slipping into a state of basically
Madness I would love to see him
grappling with the mental health of the
PTSD and just the depression of what
this situation would cause I think there
are a lot of actual really good issues
that they could tackle with that
we could also see maybe a villain or
some sort of bad guy who's called up to
the destiny and we could see flashbacks
of Eli surviving those encounters we
could also see the opportunity of
bringing back a few guest stars a few
from the SGU but also don't forget Eli
did actually meet
um Colonel O'Neill so we could get RDA
back
um just for a special because I would
have imagining him like basically
talking to himself and imagining all
these people so there's lots of
opportunities for things like that
foreign
episode series obviously by the end of
it
um the power sources they've brought to
get home with initially won't work
they'll almost die
um but probably Eli will figure out a
way to make it work and they'll get home
at the nick of time I think then we see
the destiny maybe like break up or
something and or just even better maybe
just just floating off into the black
that would be a great way to end that
series
then though we'd have to decide what to
do with Eli obviously you'd have his
demons you need to have his ghosts and
he'd have PTSD and real mental ancestors
to deal with but also he'd have a new
home and a new future so guys get into
the comments and tell me what you think
what would you like e like to then go on
to do in this imaginary new series that
I've made up would you like him to join
a team and maybe go on to have
adventures in another series within the
SGC or remember when he's basically now
an expert in ancient technology would
you actually like to see him join the
SGC and be part of this Hub of
characters that I think all the other
series could then hang off
you get into the comments you tell me
you decide so that's how I think they
could bring the SGU back and save Eli
but if I was doing it only say velai if
they did this I think they could create
a little 10 episode series it would be
really exciting and a story that's
really worth telling the cynic in me
says that they've been doing it just to
appease the hardcore fans there's a real
real hardcore story to tell so
get into the comments tell me what you
think what do we want to do with Eli now
we've saved him and do you think this
idea has any Merit do you think my
theory about why they would bring SGU
back holds any water or am I just being
a cynical old fart
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out also
if you enjoy the content go and hit the
join button because that really helps us
out and become a fully fledged side
tracker as always guys please stay safe
I'll see you next time
[Music]